AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(APPLAUSE, CHEERING)
ONE OF TODAY'S LESSER KNOWN
HOLIDAYS IS MOLDY CHEESE DAY
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING WORTH
CELEBRATING, SO TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS CHEESE SONGS.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE FETA OFF
WITHOUT YOU OR GOUDA
VIBRATIONS OR MONTEREY JACK
FLASH.
I'M WEARING A DICK SASH.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M ALSO GOING TO PUT 60
SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, STARTING
NOW. GO.
(BELL DINGS)
GRACE HELBIG?
>> BRIE BIRD.
>> HARDWICK: YES. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
HENRY?
>> IN-A-GOUDA-DA-VIDA.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
>> MIRA?
>> WHILE MY GRUYÈRE GENTLY
WEEPS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
GRACE.
>> RICOTTA GET OUT OF THIS
PLACE.
>> HARDWICK: OH, MY GOD.
POINTS.
MATT.
>> CRASH INTO BRIE?
>> HARDWICK: OH! POINTS!
POINTS!
(APPLAUSE)
WELL PLAYED.
GRACE.
>> ONE IS THE PROVOLONLIEST
NUMBER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
GRACE.
>> CURD LINES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> SGT. PEPPER JACK'S
PROVOLONELEY HAVARTI'S CLUB
BAND.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS.
YEAH.
(BELL DINGS)
HENRY.
>> UH, ♪ CAN'T FIND NO FETA
MINE. ♪
>> HARDWICK: POINTS, YES.
(BUZZING)
POINTS.
PERFECT.